This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing evidence-based results-driven treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28. Newport treats clients who are struggling with mental health conditions, co-occurring disorders, and behavioral issues like lying and risk-taking. Newport's outpatient and residential programs around the country provide supportive, caring environments where adolescents and young adults can find long-term sustainable healing. Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. From Pinocchio to the boy who cried wolf, many classic children's tales tell the stories of children who lie and get their comeuppance for it. It's no surprise that these morality tales are so popular.
本期节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，他们为12至28岁的青少年和年轻人提供基于证据、以结果为导向的治疗。Newport治疗的客户包括那些正在与心理健康状况、共病以及撒谎和冒险等行为问题作斗争的人。Newport在全国各地的门诊和住院项目提供支持性、关怀性的环境，让青少年和年轻人能够找到长期可持续的康复。欲了解更多信息，请访问Newport Healthcare.com。从《木偶奇遇记》到《狼来了》，许多经典的儿童故事讲述了孩子们撒谎并因此受到惩罚的故事。这些道德故事如此受欢迎也就不足为奇了。
Honesty is a universally valued trait, and most parents want to raise their children to be honest. So the first time that a parent catches a child in a lie, it may come as an unpleasant surprise. But psychologists' research has found that lying is a normal part of childhood. In fact, it's a developmental milestone. It's only possible once children have developed some self-control and the ability to understand another person's mental state.
诚实是一种普遍受推崇的品质，大多数父母都希望把孩子培养成诚实的人。因此，当父母第一次发现孩子撒谎时，可能会感到一种不愉快的惊讶。但心理学家的研究发现，撒谎是童年时期正常的一部分。事实上，这是一个发展的里程碑。只有当孩子发展出一定的自我控制能力和理解他人心理状态的能力时，撒谎才有可能发生。
So why do kids lie? And how young does lying start? Do kids lie more than adults? How do children understand the morality of lying and how does their understanding change as they get older? What kind of lies are normal for children and when does lying become a problem? How do kids think about the gray areas of telling white lies,
那么，孩子们为什么要撒谎？撒谎从多大开始？孩子比大人撒谎多吗？孩子们是如何理解撒谎的道德性的，随着年龄的增长，他们的理解又发生了怎样的变化？什么样的谎言对孩子来说是正常的，撒谎在什么时候会成为一个问题？孩子们是如何看待说善意谎言的灰色地带的，
keeping secrets, and tattling? And how can parents encourage truth-telling and honesty in their children? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Victoria Talwar, a professor in the Department of Educational and Count
保守秘密和打小报告？父母又该如何鼓励孩子说真话和保持诚实？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是维多利亚·塔尔瓦尔博士，她是麦吉尔大学教育与咨询心理学系的教授，在那里她研究儿童说真话和说谎的行为。她的研究考察了影响儿童撒谎的认知、社会和文化因素，以及儿童如何理解撒谎和诚实的道德含义。她还研究与儿童在法庭上的目击证词以及儿童和青少年在网络空间中的社交互动（包括网络欺凌）相关的问题。她的书《关于撒谎的真相：在每个年龄和阶段教导孩子诚实》已于7月由美国心理学会出版。感谢您今天加入我们，塔尔瓦尔博士。谢谢你邀请我。
Counseling Psychology at McGill University, where she studies children's truth-telling and lie-telling behavior. Her research examines the cognitive, social, and cultural factors that affect children's lying, as well as how children understand the moral implications of lying and honesty. She also studies issues related to children's eyewitness testimony in court and kids' and teen social interactions in cyberspace, including cyberbullying. Her book, The Truth About Lying, teaching honesty to children at every age and stage was published by APA in July. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Talwar. Thank you for having me.
（接上文）感谢您今天加入我们，塔尔瓦尔博士。谢谢你邀请我。
Let's start with an idea I just mentioned, which is that lying is a normal part of children's development. At what age do kids start to lie and what cognitive abilities do they need to have in place in order to lie well? Yeah, it actually emerges along with other sort of cognitive abilities that happen in the preschool years. So that's why we say it's a normal part of development because it's part of these abilities, these positive cognitive abilities that develop in children, which are abilities like they understand that other people have other thought bubbles, I say, coming from their mind. So
让我们从我刚才提到的一个观点开始，那就是撒谎是儿童发展的正常部分。孩子们从几岁开始撒谎，他们需要具备什么样的认知能力才能撒谎得好？是的，它实际上是随着学龄前出现的其他认知能力一起出现的。这就是为什么我们说它是发展的正常部分，因为它是儿童发展的这些能力——这些积极的认知能力——的一部分，比如他们理解其他人有其他的“思想泡泡”，我是这么说的，来自他们的头脑。所以
the idea is that we understand that, you know, somebody else has different ideas, different thoughts, different beliefs, knowledge, and desires that are different from ours. So if you imagine in their thought bubble, they're kind of thinking their thoughts of what they think about the world and what they know about the world. But a young child doesn't understand that. They don't realize that what they know, someone else might not know, or vice versa. So they don't really yet start to understand that until about sort of the preschool years of about, you know, three, four, five, six they're starting to develop these abilities. And certainly by five that most children understand it. Once you start to understand that, that other people have sort of these mental thoughts, mental
这个想法是，我们理解，你知道，别人有不同的想法、不同的思想、不同的信念、知识和欲望，这些都与我们不同。所以如果你想象在他们的思想泡泡里，他们正在思考他们对世界的看法以及他们对世界的了解。但年幼的孩子并不理解这一点。他们没有意识到他们所知道的，别人可能不知道，反之亦然。所以他们直到学龄前，大约三、四、五、六岁时，才真正开始理解这一点，他们开始发展这些能力。当然，到五岁时，大多数孩子都能理解了。一旦你开始理解这一点，即其他人有这些心理思想、心理
representations in their minds, these knowledge, beliefs that are different, that can be different, you can understand that someone else could have a false belief about what is true. So, you know, if I go and put the juice in the fridge and then later you move the juice and put it on the counter, I will still have a false belief that the juice is in the fridge. but a young child doesn't have that yet knowledge. They'll think that if they saw you move it, that I will have the knowledge that they have, which is the juices on the counter.
头脑中的表征，这些知识、信念是不同的，是可以不同的，你就能理解别人可能对什么是真实的有一个错误的信念。所以，你知道，如果我去把果汁放进冰箱，后来你把果汁移走并放在柜台上，我仍然会有一个错误的信念，认为果汁在冰箱里。但年幼的孩子还没有那种知识。他们会认为，如果他们看到你移动了它，我就会拥有他们所拥有的知识，即果汁在柜台上。
They don't have the idea that I could have a false belief in my mind. Once you start to understand that someone can have a false belief about reality, then you also can understand that you can start to manipulate that and potentially instill a false belief in others. And this ability to understand other people's sort of thought bubbles, as I call them, is a really important part of development because we want children to be able to start understanding that other people have different thoughts and knowledge and to be able to do perspective taking, which is sort of this is building towards those sort of these building blocks
他们没有我脑子里可能有错误信念的概念。一旦你开始理解某人可能对现实有错误的信念，那么你也就能够理解你可以开始操纵它，并可能在他人心中灌输一个错误的信念。这种理解他人“思想泡泡”（我称之为）的能力是发展中非常重要的一部分，因为我们希望孩子能够开始理解其他人有不同的想法和知识，并能够进行换位思考，这正在构建这些……这些构建模块
of perspective taking. This is a very important part in our social development to be able to interact with each others. So this is a positive development. And this cognitive development happens in the preschool years, but it also means that children also start to tell lies because they also understand that maybe, you know, if I lie about doing my homework, mom might believe it and I get out of doing my homework. So this is sort of a product of this positive development that's happening in children. Are there ages or stages in development when lying is more common among kids? So in that preschool years, you start to see it emerge.
换位思考。这是我们社会发展中非常重要的一部分，能够与他人互动。所以这是一个积极的发展。这种认知发展发生在学龄前，但也意味着孩子们也开始撒谎，因为他们也明白，也许，你知道，如果我撒谎说我做了家庭作业，妈妈可能会相信，我就不用做家庭作业了。所以这是一种发生在儿童身上的积极发展的产物。在儿童发展的过程中，是否有某些年龄或阶段撒谎更为常见？在学龄前，你开始看到它出现。
And I would say that, you know, you sometimes see it emerge a little earlier for children, especially children who are, you know, have older siblings. Researchers show that children have older siblings might parents notice their children telling sort of small fibs earlier. And that's partly because, one, they may see a model by the older siblings, but also, too, you know, this is part of like sort of negotiating the social relations with their, with their siblings potentially. And also younger children with an older sibling
我想说的是，你知道，你有时会看到它在孩子身上出现得更早，特别是那些有年长兄弟姐妹的孩子。研究人员表明，有年长兄弟姐妹的孩子，父母会更早注意到他们的孩子在撒谎。这部分是因为，第一，他们可能会看到年长兄弟姐妹的榜样，但第二，你知道，这是与他们的兄弟姐妹协商社会关系的一部分。而且，有年长兄弟姐妹的年幼孩子
have more advanced sort of cognitive development happening because of all their social interactions. It advances their cognition. So you see this may see this ability a little earlier. But generally it's happening kind of, you start to see some children two and a half three. By four years of age, most children are telling occasional lies. And so it emerges at this age.
由于他们所有的社交互动，他们的认知发展更先进。这促进了他们的认知。所以你可能会更早地看到这种能力。但总的来说，它正在发生，你开始看到一些两岁半到三岁的孩子。到四岁时，大多数孩子偶尔会撒谎。所以它在这个年龄出现。
But it kind of increases in frequency as they're kind of getting a little older. They are not necessarily the best at line, so you'll notice that. But as they go through the school age years, they start to learn about when it's appropriate and not appropriate to lie. But on the other hand, they're getting better at lying. We see a decrease in some types of lies by adolescents. But on the other hand, we see an increase in lying where adolescents may be more likely to conceal information that they consider as personal information.
但随着他们年龄的增长，频率会增加。他们不一定是最擅长撒谎的，所以你会注意到这一点。但随着他们进入学龄期，他们开始学习什么时候撒谎是合适的，什么时候不合适。但另一方面，他们变得更擅长撒谎了。我们看到青少年在某些类型的谎言上有所减少。但另一方面，我们看到撒谎有所增加，青少年可能更有可能隐瞒他们认为是个人信息的信息。
that they don't necessarily want to disclose. And as we go through adolescence, it seems to decline as we get into early sort of adulthood. And certainly, as we go through the age range, as we look at, for instance, seniors, they tend to lie less than sort of middle-aged adults. So there's like a downward arc as we go through. At what point does a child actually understand that he or she is not telling the truth? Young children, very, very young children. So sometimes parents say, well, my child lied to me. And we're talking about very young children, like a two-year-old. And sometimes it's not necessarily that the child understands that they lie. What they're giving is kind of what we call wish fulfillment. So like you might point off into the, you know, horizon. Hey, do you see the ferris wheel over there? And the child says yes. But of course, there's no ferris wheel in the horizon. And you say, well, that child's just lied to me. You know, they didn't see it. But what the child is saying, I want to see what you see.
他们不一定想透露。随着我们进入青春期，当我们进入成年早期时，它似乎会下降。当然，随着我们经历年龄范围，当我们观察，例如，老年人时，他们往往比中年人撒谎少。所以我们经历的过程中有一个向下的弧线。孩子在什么时候真正理解他或她没有说实话？年幼的孩子，非常非常年幼的孩子。所以有时父母会说，我的孩子对我撒谎了。我们谈论的是非常年幼的孩子，比如两岁。有时并不一定意味着孩子理解他们在撒谎。他们所给予的是我们所谓的“愿望满足”。所以就像你可能会指向地平线，嘿，你看到那边的摩天轮了吗？孩子说看到了。但当然，地平线上没有摩天轮。你说，嗯，那个孩子刚才对我撒谎了。你知道，他们没看到。但孩子说的是，我想看到你所看到的。
Like, I want to see it. Yes, yes, where is it? You know, and they're kind of looking because they're used to adults asking them things and, you know, learning to comply with those questions. So sometimes they are giving these what people think are false answers. It's really kind of wish for them. Yeah, I want to be able to see that fear as well. Yes, yes, kind of thing.
就像，我想看到它。是的，是的，它在哪里？你知道，他们有点在寻找，因为他们习惯了成年人问他们事情，你知道，学习去顺从这些问题。所以有时他们会给出人们认为是错误答案的回答。这实际上是一种愿望满足。是的，我想能够看到那个摩天轮。是的，是的，那种感觉。
But by the time we get to about in that four to five range, for sure by this age, they start to understand that, you know, the intentionality behind lying. And so definitely they're telling. intentional lies around that age range. So when do kids start to understand and tell what we call pro-social lies, the kind of lies that most of us will tell sometimes that are designed to avoid hurting someone's feelings, such as you say to a gift giver, gee, I really love those socks when you actually would have preferred something else or just blurting out, boy, Aunt Margie, you sure look fat.
但当我们达到四到五岁左右时，肯定到了这个年龄，他们开始理解撒谎背后的意图。所以毫无疑问，他们在那个年龄段说的是有意的谎言。那么孩子们什么时候开始理解并说出我们所谓的“亲社会谎言”呢？这是我们大多数人有时会说的谎言，旨在避免伤害某人的感情，比如你对送礼物的人说，天哪，我真的很喜欢这些袜子，而你其实更喜欢别的东西，或者脱口而出，天哪，玛吉阿姨，你看起来真胖。
I mean, when the kids realize that you shouldn't be saying those things and that they are more or less acceptable lies? So we did a study. Our first study we did, we did exactly like what you said, we gave them an undesirable gift. And that one, it was like a bar of soap, Lysol soap. There was like a bucket of different gifts they could get. And there were lots of neat toys, but they got like the Lysol soap. And then the gift giver asked them how they liked it after they unwrapped it.
我是说，当孩子们意识到你不应该说这些话，而且它们或多或少是可以接受的谎言时？所以我们做了一项研究。我们做的第一项研究，我们做的正是你所说的，我们给了他们一份不想要的礼物。那一次，就像一块肥皂，Lysol肥皂。有一堆他们可以得到的不同礼物。有很多很棒的玩具，但他们得到了像Lysol肥皂那样的东西。然后送礼物的人在他们拆开后问他们喜不喜欢。
And what we found was, and this was children between three and 11 years of age. And we found that like even some of the three-year-olds was. say, yeah, I like it. You know, yeah, the gift camera say, hey, do you like the gift I gave you? Yes. But we did find that the younger children couldn't really tell you why they liked it, whereas the older children could. But then we did a follow-up study.
我们发现的是，这是三到11岁的孩子。我们发现，甚至一些三岁的孩子也会说，是的，我喜欢它。你知道，送礼物的人会说，嘿，你喜欢我给你的礼物吗？是的。但我们确实发现，年幼的孩子无法真正告诉你为什么他们喜欢它，而年长的孩子可以。但后来我们做了一项后续研究。
So that study we did, we did that in Canada, and a follow-up study we did with children in mainland China. But this time we explored whether they would, what their explanation was. And we did it with younger children, so seven, nine, and 11-year-olds. And what we found was when we later on someone asked them, well, why did you tell that person you like the gift? And what we found was younger children will tell that lie for, they're not so much telling
所以那项研究我们是在加拿大做的，我们对中国大陆的孩子做了一项后续研究。但这一次我们探讨了他们是否会，他们的解释是什么。我们对年幼的孩子做了这项研究，七岁、九岁和11岁的孩子。我们发现的是，当后来有人问他们，嗯，你为什么告诉那个人你喜欢这个礼物？我们发现的是，年幼的孩子会说那个谎，他们并不是那么为了亲社会的原因而在那种情况下撒谎。
it for pro-social reasons when they lie in that situation. It's more like they fear that the person will get upset with them. So there's more related to their own self that they're thinking, self-preservation in a way. Now, those children were much more likely. younger children are much more likely to be blunt truth tellers. And a lot of people have funny stories about their child sort of telling the blunt truth in an inappropriate moment, right? Those children are much more likely to tell blunt truth. And those children that do tell these lies in this situation, they're much more likely to be doing it for self-preservation.
更多的是他们害怕那个人会因为他们而生气。所以这更多地与他们自己有关，他们在思考，在某种程度上是自我保护。现在，那些孩子更有可能。年幼的孩子更有可能成为直言不讳的真话讲述者。很多人都有关于他们的孩子在不适当的时刻说出直言不讳的真话的有趣故事，对吧？那些孩子更有可能说出直言不讳的真话。而那些在这种情况下的确撒谎的孩子，他们更有可能是为了自我保护。
They're worried that the person's going to be upset with them if they say that they don't like it. But as you get older up to like going up to 11 years of age, you have a. significant increase in children who are telling these lies, these sort of politeness lies. And when you ask them why they're doing it, you get a significant increase in those children giving sort of other oriented answers. And when I say that, I mean, they're saying things like, she'll feel really bad if I say that, you know, she was so happy to give me the gift. I don't want to hurt her feelings. So sort of through those school years, they're definitely learning sort of the social norms and social conventions of politeness and they may start telling lies in order to preserve
他们担心如果他们说不喜欢，那个人会生他们的气。但随着你年龄增长到11岁，你会看到说这些谎言——这些礼貌谎言——的孩子有显著增加。当你问他们为什么这样做时，你会得到那些给出以他人为导向的答案的孩子有显著增加。当我这么说时，我的意思是，他们会说这样的话，比如，如果我那样说，她会感觉很糟糕，你知道，她很高兴给我这个礼物。我不想伤害她的感情。所以通过这些学龄期，他们肯定在学习礼貌的社会规范和社会习俗，他们可能会开始撒谎，为了维护
another person's feelings or to protect them from feeling bad. And we did another study, a follow-up study in Canada where we had children. So in this case, they got just like your example, they got a pair of knitted woolen brown socks. And again, there was like, they could have got lots of things. And my graduate student, Mina Poplicker at the time did the study and she would give them to them and she'd say, oh, I hope you. really like this, I made them myself. And they would open it up and they'd find like woolen socks. And they kind of, oh, okay. And in one case, it was a low stakes lie. So they had previously gotten another toy, a gift toy, and they could keep both of them. But in another condition,
另一个人的感情，或者保护他们不感到难过。我们在加拿大做了另一项研究，一项后续研究，我们让孩子们参与。所以在这个例子中，他们得到了就像你的例子一样，他们得到了一双针织的棕色羊毛袜。同样，有，他们本可以得到很多东西。我当时的研究生米娜·波普利克做了这项研究，她会把它们给他们，她说，哦，我希望你真的喜欢这个，我自己做的。他们会打开它，发现是羊毛袜。他们有点，哦，好吧。在一种情况下，这是一个低风险的谎言。所以他们之前得到了另一个玩具，一个礼物玩具，他们可以保留两个。但在另一种情况下，
it was a high-stake lie, a more altruistic lie, because they could only keep one of the gifts. So if they said they didn't like them, then they could give back the socks and keep the other fun toy. but then they might be hurting her feelings. So for them to say that they like it, it was altruistic in that there was a potential cost to them for saying that, but this would sort of benefit by not hurting meanest feelings. And what we found was, again, we did this with preschool all the way into sort of 11-year-olds, and we found that with age children were much more likely in the high cost situation
这是一个高风险的谎言，一个更利他的谎言，因为他们只能保留其中一个礼物。所以如果他们说他们不喜欢它们，那么他们可以把袜子还回去并保留另一个有趣的玩具。但那样他们可能会伤害她的感情。所以对他们来说，说他们喜欢它，是利他的，因为说出来对他们来说有一个潜在的代价，但这会通过不伤害米娜的感情而有所裨益。我们发现的是，同样，我们对从学龄前一直到11岁左右的孩子做了这项研究，我们发现随着年龄的增长，孩子们在代价高昂的情况下更有可能说，哦，是的，我喜欢它们。非常感谢你。你给我羊毛袜真是太好了。所以随着孩子年龄的增长，他们更有可能为了别人的利益而撒谎，即使对自己有潜在的代价。你也研究孩子们如何思考撒谎的道德性，以及特定类型的谎言是正确还是错误。这种道德理解随着孩子年龄的增长是如何发展和变化的？所以非常年幼的孩子通常把撒谎归为不真实、不正确的事情。但结果是，他们有时会过度概括这一点，他们基于事实性。所以例如，如果你错误地说了一些事情，他们会称之为谎言。所以例如，如果我相信
where they had to give back the fun toy and had to keep the woolen socks. they were much more likely to say, oh, yes, I like them. Thank you very much. It's very nice of you to give me woolen sauce. So as children get older, they're much more likely to tell lies for the benefit of someone else at even a potential cost to themselves. You also study how kids think about the morality of lying and whether particular kinds of lies are right or wrong. How does that moral understanding develop and change as children? age? So very young children often lump lying as something that is not true, not correct. But as a result, they can sometimes overgeneralize this to, they sort of base it on factuality. So for instance, if you say something by mistake, they'll call that a lie. So for instance, if I believe
（接上文）所以例如，如果我相信
that the outdoor pool this summer is open from 11 a.m. onwards and I tell the children, Okay, we can go at 11 o'clock, and it turns out it's not open to 1 p.m., they'll say, oh, well, you told a lie. But I was just a mistaken belief. So in my thought bubble, I had what I believe was a true belief that it was open at 11am. But that was not the actual reality. The reality is at 1 p.m. So what's different here is that I did not intend to lie. I made a genuine mistake.
今年夏天室外游泳池从上午11点开始开放，我告诉孩子们，好吧，我们可以在11点去，结果发现它要到下午1点才开放，他们会说，哦，好吧，你撒谎了。但我只是一个错误的信念。所以在我的思想泡泡里，我有一个我认为是真实信念的东西，即它在上午11点开放。但那不是实际的现实。现实是下午1点。所以这里不同的是，我并没有打算撒谎。我犯了一个真正的错误。
I made an incorrect statement based on what I believe to be the true state of reality. young children don't understand this. So they will often call this a lie. And as they go through sort of school age, like six to 11, they start to understand sort of the intentionality behind lies that the person is actually intending to deceive you. They're intending to make a false statement to make someone else believe something that that's not true. So they start to understand that as they get older. So for instance, if I decide to trick you and do a mean trick and tell you that the suing pull is open at 11am, but I know that it's open at 1 p.m. So you go along at 11 p.m. And discover to your disappointment that you can't get in, that is a lie where I know that when the
我基于我认为是真实的现实状态做出了一个不正确的陈述。年幼的孩子不理解这一点。所以他们经常会称之为谎言。随着他们经历学龄期，比如六到11岁，他们开始理解谎言背后的意图，即那个人实际上打算欺骗你。他们打算做出虚假的陈述，让别人相信一些不真实的事情。所以随着年龄的增长，他们开始理解这一点。所以例如，如果我决定捉弄你，做一个恶作剧，告诉你游泳池在上午11点开放，但我知道它在下午1点开放。所以你在上午11点去，失望地发现你进不去，那是一个谎言，我知道游泳池什么时候开放，但我仍然做出了虚假的陈述，打算让你相信它。因此，我打算欺骗你。那么在撒谎和作弊之间的界限上导航呢？让孩子理解作弊实际上是一种撒谎形式的最好方法是什么？如果他们甚至理解这一点，这重要吗？我们谈论撒谎。所以撒谎是一种口头的，通常是口头的陈述，目的是欺骗。它属于不诚实的范畴。现在，我们可以有一系列不诚实的行为，包括作弊。通常作弊和撒谎是一起出现的，因为，你知道，如果你在考试中作弊，然后有人问你，你是怎么知道的？你对此撒谎，或者你被问到，你作弊了吗？或者类似的事情？你对此撒谎。所以它是，
pull is open, but I've still made a false statement intending you to believe it. And therefore, I've intended to deceive you. What about navigating the line between lying and cheating? What's the best way to get children to understand that cheating is, in effect, a form of lying? And does it matter if they even understand that? We talk about lying. So lying is a verbal, usually a verbal statement made with the intention to deceive. It's under the umbrella of dishonesty. Now, we can have a range of dishonest acts, including cheating. Often cheating and lying come together because, you know, if you cheat on a test and then someone asks you, how did you know that? You lie about it or you are asked, did you cheat or something? You lie about it. So it's,
（接上文）它也关于更广泛的关于诚实的重要性以及不参与不诚实行为的讨论。你刚才提到你在加拿大和中国做过研究。你是否发现不同国家和文化的孩子对撒谎的道德性的看法不同？所以有一件事是普遍的，那就是人们认为诚实非常重要。这是一种高度重视的行为，我们期待在别人的品格中看到它。我们对它的评价非常积极。
It's also about sort of the wider discussion about the importance of honesty and not engaging in dishonest acts. You mentioned a little while ago you've done studies in Canada and China. Do you find that children in different countries and cultures think differently about the morality of lying? So one thing that is universal is that people think honesty is really important. It's a highly valued behavior and we look forward in the character of others. We rate it very positively.
诚实真的很重要。从文化到文化变化的是那些可能不总是诚实是可以接受的情况，例如。我们有文化认可的情况，我们说出我们认为不一定被视为谎言的话。所以，例如，在北美，告诉孩子们关于圣诞老人的事情非常普遍。然而很少有父母认为这可能是在撒谎，因为这是我们告诉孩子的一种文化认可的故事，我们甚至经常不把它看作是欺骗的范畴。所以我们有这些领域，我们可能对撒谎不那么负面。再给你举个例子，嗯，实际上，这是孔力的一项研究。他在中国和加拿大做了一项研究，他们给出了小片段，孩子们必须评估他们认为角色所说的是好还是坏。
Honesty is really important. What changes from culture to culture is the situations where it may be acceptable to not always be honest, for instance. And we have sort of culturally sanctioned situations where we tell sort of what we perceive as not necessarily being lies. So, for instance, in North America, it's very common to tell children about Santa Claus. yet few pairs think about it as potentially lying because it's a culturally sanctioned kind of story that we tell children, and we don't even see it often in the realm of deception. So we have these sort of areas where we may be less negative about lying. To give you another example, well, actually, this is a study by Kong Lee. He did a study in China and in Canada, where they gave vignettes, And the children had to evaluate whether they thought what the character said was good or bad.
在一些小片段中，比如故事角色会在老师不在房间时打扫房间。老师会回到房间问他们是谁做的。在一些故事中，孩子诚实地说他们做的。在一些故事中，孩子会撒谎，不说他们做的。在加拿大，孩子们总是积极地评价说真话，消极地评价撒谎，无论它是关于做故事中的某事。某件坏事、越轨的事，还是做这件积极的事，比如打扫房间。但在中国，随着年龄的增长，孩子们越来越倾向于不那么积极地评价关于打扫房间的说真话，他们更倾向于更积极地评价撒谎
And in some of the vignettes, like the story character would clean up the room while the teacher was out of the room. And the teacher would come back in the room and ask them who did it. And in some of the stories the child said they did it truthfully. And some of the stories the child would lie and not say that they did it. In Canada, children always rated the truth telling positively and the lying negatively, whether it was about doing some of the story. something bad, transgressive, or doing this positive thing, cleaning up a room, for instance. But in China, with age, children were increasingly more likely to rate the truth-telling about cleaning up the room less positively, and they were more likely to rate the lying more positively
随着年龄的增长。所以他们更有可能说在这种情况撒谎是可以的。这是因为在那种文化中，谦虚的原则非常重要。所以在那种情况下撒谎变得更容易接受，因为它被视为更谦逊、更低调。所以我们有社会情况，我们可能认为撒谎是一件不那么负面的事情。所以就像我们刚才举的收到礼物的例子，通常孩子们，例如在北美，被父母社会化，你知道，说，哦，非常感谢。并说他们喜欢这个礼物，因为它被认为非常粗鲁，去告诉一个人，啊，我不喜欢这个，或者，你知道，你为什么要给我这个？我想要别的东西。所以有些情况在文化上可能因地而异，就
with age. So they were more likely to say it was okay to lie in this situation as they got older. And that's because within that culture, the principle of modesty is very important. And so it becomes more acceptable to lie in that situation because it's seen as being more self-effacing and more modest. So we have social situations where we may consider lying a less negative thing. So just like the example we gave a moment ago with getting a gift, often children, for instance, in North America, are socialized by parents to, you know, say, oh, thank you very much. And to say they like the gift because it's considered really. rude to tell a person, ah, I don't like this or, you know, why did you get me this? I wanted something else. So there are situations that culturally may vary from place to place in terms of
我们如何宽恕或我们如何原谅某些谎言。本期节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，为12至28岁正在与心理健康状况和行为问题作斗争的年轻人提供可及且合乎道德的治疗。Newport的综合全人方法解决了可能导致抑郁、焦虑、创伤后应激障碍、药物滥用和饮食失调的潜在创伤。通过门诊和住院项目，Newport提供根据每个客户的个人需求和历史量身定制的治疗计划，结合了临床、体验式和学术编程。青少年和年轻人学习与家人、同龄人、导师和他们自己建立诚实、真实关系的技能。
how we condone or we sort of excuse certain lies. This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, delivering accessible and ethical treatment to young people ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with mental health conditions and behavioral issues. Newport's integrated whole-person approach addresses the underlying trauma that can lead to depression, anxiety, PTSD, substance abuse, and eating disorders. With outpatient and residential programs, Newport provides tailored treatment plans designed for each client's individual needs and history, incorporating a blend of clinical, experiential, and academic programming. Teens and young adults learn skills for building honest, authentic relationships with family, peers, mentors, and themselves.
欲了解更多信息，请访问Newport Healthcare.com。这是一个处于你新书核心的问题。父母如何鼓励孩子说真话？如果你想把孩子培养成诚实的人，什么有效，什么无效？首先，如果这对你真的很重要，你希望你的孩子诚实，并且你希望他们对你说真话，那么你需要积极地教导孩子关于这一点。仅仅认为他们会通过渗透作用学会它并不是可行的方法。
Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. Here's a question that's at the crux of your new book. How can parents encourage truth-telling in their children? What works and what doesn't work if you want to raise your children to be honest? First of all, if this is really important to you, that you want your child to be honest, and you want them to tell you the truth, then you need to actively teach children about it. Just thinking that they'll pick it up by osmosis is not the way to go.
我们积极地教导孩子很多行为。我们积极地教导他们数字。我们积极地教导他们如何阅读。如果你希望他们参与像诚实这样的亲社会行为，你也可以教导这些。事实上，这是最有效的方法，即真正强调它们，谈论它们，强调它们，并教导孩子们它们。所以这意味着什么？你怎么教他们？
We actively teach children about a lot of behaviors. We actively teach them their numbers. We actively teach them how to read. If you want them to engage in pro-social behaviors like honesty, you can also teach those. And in fact, that's the most effective thing to do is to really stress those, talk about them, emphasize them, and teach children them. So that means what does that mean that? How do you teach them?
嗯，这意味着从很小的时候就开始做强调这一点的事情，并给你关于为什么你重视这种行为的信息。这意味着你可以读故事。你可以在很小的时候和孩子一起读故事。孩子们特别喜欢故事。它们可以成为很好的机制，在某种程度上给他们那个信息，也使它对他们来说是可以理解的。它也可以成为你与他们进行关于这些不同原则的对话的催化剂，以及关于故事角色是如何表现的，以及为什么他们那样表现。这是你可以随着他们年龄增长而一直做的事情。你知道，年幼的时候，
Well, it means like from an early age doing things that emphasize that and give you the message about why you value this behavior. That means you can read stories. You can read stories at a very young age with children. Children are particularly loved stories. and they can be really good mechanisms to sort of give them that message and also to make it understandable to them. It also can be a catalyst for you to have conversations with them about these different principles and about how the story characters behaved and why they behave like that. And that's something you can do throughout as they get older too. You know, younger age,
你要有图画书，随着年龄增长，你知道，即使是年龄较大的孩子。年龄较大的小学或，你知道，初中孩子，你可能仍然在为了娱乐而与他们一起阅读，即使他们自己能阅读，你可以谈论事情，或者只是对他们正在读的书感兴趣，你可以谈论学生角色，当他们表现出像诚实这样的行为时，你可以谈论它们，或者当他们不诚实时，谈论那些情况。当然，随着他们年龄增长，他们看到撒谎和说真话的情况变得更加微妙，你可以进行持续的对话。所以进行持续的对话也确保如果，
you're going to have picture books as you get older, you know, even an older age child. older elementary or, you know, middle school child, you may still be engaging in reading with them for entertainment, even though they can read themselves, you can talk about things, or just be interested in the books they're doing, you can talk about student characters, and when they show behaviors like honesty, you can talk about them, or when they're dishonest and talk about those situations. And of course, as they get older, the situations where they see lying and truth-telling become more nuanced, and you can have. have an ongoing conversation about that. So having an ongoing conversation also make sure that if you,
你知道，如果诚实是你重视的东西，那么你想要在你的孩子身上认可它。你知道，如果他们诚实，我们经常忘记认可它。因为他们有时是对越轨行为诚实，对吧？所以我们直接跳到越轨行为。什么？你做了什么？但我们想要说，比如，我们应该花点时间至少给他们认可，他们做了勇敢的事情，并告诉了你关于它的真相。所以说，你知道，我不高兴你，你知道，弄坏了我的，你知道，我的手机，但我很高兴。我很高兴你至少告诉了我关于它的真相。然后你可以进行关于，你知道，为什么他们弄坏了手机或什么的对话。但当他们诚实时给他们一些认可很重要。
you know, if honesty is something you value, then you want to recognize it in your children. You know, if they're honest, we often forget to recognize it. Like, because they're sometimes being honest about a transgression, right? So we jump right to the transgression. What? You did what? But we want to say, like, we should take a moment to at least give them recognition that they've done the brave thing and told you the truth about it. So say, you know, I'm not happy that you, you know, broke my, you know, my phone, but I'm glad. I'm happy that you at least told me the truth about it. And then you can have a conversation about, you know, why they broke the phone or whatever. But giving them some recognition when they're honest is important.
因为不仅要说，你知道，进行关于诚实重要性的对话很重要，但如果你在他们这样做时从不认可它，就像，嗯，当我诚实时，它实际上根本不重要。我没有得到任何关于它的积极反馈。我们经常只在他们撒谎时给予消极反馈。但我们也必须给予积极反馈。而且，最后，这其中一个非常重要的部分是模拟这种行为。如果你说诚实真的很重要，但随后你在你的孩子面前表现得不诚实，你的孩子会观察到这一点。所以，你知道，如果你在撒谎，你知道，他们听到你在电话里撒谎，他们知道这是一个明显的谎言，或者你在撒谎，你知道，为了以更便宜的价格进入电影院，因为你对他们的年龄撒谎或什么的。
because it's not only important to say, you know, have conversations about the importance of honesty, but then if you never recognize it when they do it, it's like, well, it doesn't actually matter at all when I'm honest. I don't get any positive feedback on it. And we often just give negative feedback when they're lying. But we also have to give the positive feedback. And also, finally, a really important piece of this is modeling the behavior. If you say honesty is really important, but then you are like being dishonest in front of your child, your child's going to observe that. So, you know, if you're lying, you know, they hear you lying on the phone and they know it's an obvious lie or you're lying, you know, to get into the movies for cheaper price because you lie about their age or whatever.
那些是他们捡起的小事情，他们只是在交流。是的，诚实确实是最好的政策。诚实很重要，但我们也可以敷衍了事。所以你也必须模拟那种行为。如果这对你真的很重要，你也应该向他们展示如何诚实。惩罚孩子撒谎怎么样？这在某种意义上有效吗，即它会让他们在未来停止撒谎？所以我们经常惩罚撒谎。
Those are little things they pick up them and they're just communicating. Yeah, honesty is really the best policy. Honesty is important, but we can fudge it too. And so you have to model that behavior as well. If it's really important to you, you should also be showing them how to be honest. What about punishing kids for lying? Does that work in the sense that it will make them stop lying going forward? So we often do punish lying.
并不是说你不应该让他们在没有任何后果的情况下撒谎。但其中一部分也是它的另一面。在他们有真话讲述时认可它。所以如果你只惩罚说谎，而从不给说真话任何认可，那么你可能实际上并没有传达说真话的价值，或者向他们展示什么是期望的行为。而且，真正那种对撒谎的威权惩罚并不一定，它可能在那个时刻阻止他们撒谎，但它并不一定区分这种行为，因为，例如，我们做了一项研究，我们发现与没有受到这种惩罚的孩子相比，在学校环境中受到非常严格的、惩罚性的体罚的孩子，他们更早学会撒谎，他们学会撒谎得更好。其中一部分是，嗯，如果你要惹上很多麻烦，而这些孩子会因为各种越轨行为而惹上很多麻烦，不仅仅是撒谎。但如果你惹上很多麻烦，可能对你所做的任何事情都有一些严厉的惩罚，撒谎实际上可以是一种减轻那些对你负面后果的方法。但如果你要尝试那种策略，你还不如孤注一掷，真正学会把它做好，让它有效。所以它可能会适得其反。所以并不是说你不应该完全忽视撒谎
And it's not that you shouldn't necessarily let them just lie without any consequence. But part of that is also the flip side. of it is recognizing the truth-telling when they have it. So if you're only punishing lie-telling and you're never giving any recognition for truth-telling, then you may not be actually communicating the value of truth-telling or showing them what the desired behavior is. And also, really sort of authoritarian punishment for lying doesn't necessarily, it may stop them lying in that moment, but it doesn't necessarily distinguish the behavior because, for instance, we did a study where we found children who had really strict sort of punitive kind of corporal
一直不为它承担后果。但你必须在一个更广泛的框架内思考它，即强化诚实并演示什么是期望的行为，并且在他们撒谎的情况之外进行对话，当你在情绪状态之外的其他时间，也要进行关于为什么诚实很重要，为什么你应该说真话，以及在不同类型的情况下说真话是什么样子的对话？你的书里有一个部分叫“灰色地带”，你谈到了两种涉及诚实和说真话的特殊情况，那就是秘密和打小报告。你建议父母如何与他们的孩子谈论什么时候是
punishment in a school setting compared to children who didn't, they learned to lie earlier and they learned to lie better. And part of that is, well, if you're going to get into a lot out of trouble, and these children would get into a lot of trouble for all sorts of transgressions, not just lying. But if you're getting into a lot, potentially have some really harsh punishments for whatever you do, lying can actually. actually be a way to mitigate those negative consequences to you. But then if you're going to try that strategy, you might as well go for broke and really learn to do it well for it to be effective. So it might backfire on you. So it's not that you should not just ignore lying completely all
保守秘密或说出来是可以的，以及什么时候有必要，真正有必要去打小报告？所以我称这些为灰色地带，因为它们确实是困难的领域，我认为，像我这样的许多父母都挣扎过，对吧？因为并非所有的秘密都是坏秘密。比如，你知道，为你的，你知道，丈夫或某人，一个朋友举办惊喜生日派对。这不是一个坏秘密，对吧？所以有些秘密是可以的。而且孩子们也有一些关于，比如他们制作的秘密藏身处之类的小秘密。所以它们通常可以非常无辜，甚至只是在短时间内被帮助的积极小事情。但另一方面，有有害的秘密。所以它是
the time and never have consequences for it. But you have to think about it within a wider framework of reinforcing honesty and demonstrating what the desired behavior is and also having conversations sort of outside the situations where they're lying, when there's other times when you're not in an emotional state, also having conversations about why honesty is important and why you should tell the truth and what does truth-telling look like in different types of situations? There's a section of your book called gray areas where you talk about two special types of situations involving honesty and truth-telling, and that's secrets and tattles. How do you suggest parents talk with their kids about when it's over?
关于教导孩子关于，你知道，不有害的秘密和有害的秘密之间的区别。并理解作为一个普遍规则，对于非常年幼的孩子，学龄前儿童、小学早期幼儿园那个年龄，他们不一定能理解那种区别。所以在那种情况下，最好还是小心不要在那个年龄使用太多的保守秘密。并且只是稍微理解他们仍然在试图理解那些区别。所以他们也不是，如果他们保守一些小，你知道，儿童游戏秘密，这不一定是一件坏事。不要对他们严厉。他们仍然，仍然在理解那个。但你想要进行的是关于，你知道，
okay to keep a secret or tell it, and when it's necessary, really necessary to tattle on somebody. So I call these gray areas, because they're really the difficult areas, I think, that a lot of parents like myself have struggled with, right? Because not all secrets are bad secrets. Like, you know, having a surprise birthday party for your, you know, your husband or one of somebody, a friend. It's not a bad secret, right? So there are secrets that are fine. And also children have like little secrets about like they have their secret hideout that they make and things like that. So often they can be very innocent and just are even positive little things that are helped for short periods of time. But on the other hand, there are harmful secrets. So it's
有我们不应该保守的有害秘密。随着他们年龄增长，你可以进行越来越多的关于那个的讨论。例如，你知道，比如没有人应该触摸他们的私处，例如，即使那个人告诉他们，不要告诉任何人，那是他们应该总是告诉你的事情，唯一被允许触摸他们私处的人是像他们的父母，当他们给他们洗澡时，或者医生，你知道，检查他们时，但这，你知道，如果任何人告诉他们，不要告诉，他们应该总是告诉他们的父母。但另一方面，一个被保守了很短时间的秘密，比如，你知道，很短的时间，比如为了惊喜派对，没有伤害附着
about teaching children about the difference between sort of, you know, secrets that are not harmful and harmful. And to understand that as a general role with very young children, the preschool children, early elementary kindergarten that age, they're not necessarily going to understand that distinction. So it's better in that case to maybe just be careful not to use a lot of secret keeping them at that age. And just to be a little bit understanding that they're still trying to understand those distinctions. So they're not also, if they're keeping little, you know, child play secrets, it's not necessarily a bad thing. Don't be harsh on them. There's still, still understanding that. But what you do want to have is a conversation about, you know,
在它上面，这些是某种无害的秘密，保守它们是可以的，但这不应该永远保守，对吧？所以，某种程度上用那个教导他们。并且随着孩子的发展，这有一种持续的对话。他们也开始理解什么是坏的保守秘密和什么是可以的之间的区别。但也许告诉你的三岁孩子关于惊喜派对并不是一个好主意。是的，因为他们更有可能成为直言不讳的真话讲述者。所以他们很可能会脱口而出。你知道妈妈有什么吗？
that there are harmful secrets that we shouldn't keep. As they get older, you can have more and more discussion with that. For instance, you know, like no one's supposed to touch their private parts, for instance, even if that someone told them, don't tell anyone, that is something that they should always tell you, that the only person who's allowed to touch their private parts is like their parents, when they're washing them or whatever, or the doctor, you know, examining them, but this is, you know, if anyone tells them, don't tell, they should always tell their parent. But on the other hand, a secret that is kept for a short amount of time, like, you know, a short amount of time, like for a surprise party, where there's no harm attached
有些有害的秘密是不应该保守的。随着孩子年龄增长，你可以和他们进行更多讨论。例如，没有人可以触碰他们的私密部位，即使有人告诉他们“不要告诉任何人”，这也是他们必须告诉你的事情。唯一被允许触碰他们私密部位的人是他们的父母（比如在洗澡时）或者医生（在检查时）。如果有人告诉他们“不要说出去”，他们一定要告诉父母。但另一方面，为了短时间保守的秘密，比如为了惊喜派对，这种没有伤害的秘密
to it, these are sort of harmless secrets that are okay to keep, but this shouldn't be kept forever, right? So, sort of teaching them with that. And that has an ongoing kind of conversation as children develop. And they start to also understand the difference between sort of what is something that is bad to keep secret and what is something that's okay. But maybe it's not a good idea to tell you a three-year-old about the surprise party. Yes, because they're more likely to be blunt truth tellers. So they're likely to blurt it out. Do you know what mommy has?
是可以保守的，但也不应该永远保密，对吧？所以要以此来教导他们。随着孩子的成长，这是一个持续的对话过程。他们也会开始理解什么是不能保守的秘密，什么是可以保守的。但也许不适合告诉三岁的孩子关于惊喜派对的事。是的，因为他们更倾向于直言不讳，很可能会脱口而出。你知道妈妈有什么吗？
She's got your present. And you know what it is? So we've talked a lot about how lying is a normal part of development, but sometimes it develops into a problem. So what's the difference between normal and problematic lying in children? And how can parents be really attuned and react appropriately? I mean, not overreact. Some kids will lie and that's okay. But how do you know when you've really got a problem?
她拿了你的礼物。你知道那是什么吗？我们讨论了很多关于撒谎是成长过程中的正常现象，但有时它会演变成一个问题。那么，儿童正常撒谎和问题撒谎之间有什么区别？父母如何才能真正保持敏锐并做出适当的反应？我的意思是，不要反应过度。有些孩子会撒谎，这没关系。但你怎么知道什么时候真的出了问题？
So I have to say that most cases, there's not a problem. The first time you observe your child lying, you're not happy about it. it. But on the other hand, you know, don't freak out about it. It's a, like I said, at the start, it's a normal thing that they start to understand that they can do and they start to learn. And over time, you're talking to them about honesty and they get socialized that they understand that this is not, you know, something that they should do frequently. And to also understand that, you know, as a behavior, the majority of adults tell occasional lies. So by and large, most adults are honest most of the time, but the research with adults show that adults tell
所以我必须说，在大多数情况下，这不是问题。当你第一次观察到孩子撒谎时，你不会感到高兴。但另一方面，你知道，不要为此惊慌失措。就像我开头说的那样，这是他们开始理解自己能做什么并开始学习的一件正常的事情。随着时间的推移，你和他们谈论诚实，他们会被社会化，理解这不是他们应该经常做的事情。还要理解，作为一种行为，大多数成年人也会偶尔撒谎。所以总的来说，大多数成年人在大多数时候是诚实的，但针对成年人的研究表明，成年人会
the occasional lie here and there. So also keep that in mind, right? To be more, you know, understanding with your child and also not to freak out that the first time you see a lie, it doesn't mean your child is going to have a problem. Also, you're going to see your child go through periods of time where they're like trying that behavior. You know, they've learned that they can do it. And you have to just keep on teach thing in them. and reinforcing the importance of honesty with them and be patient. And by and large, most of them will start to be less likely to lie and only lie occasionally may be in a situation where they're trying to be polite
偶尔撒谎。所以也要记住这一点，对吧？要对你的孩子多一些理解，也不要因为第一次看到撒谎就惊慌失措，这并不意味着你的孩子会有问题。此外，你会看到你的孩子经历一些尝试这种行为的时期。你知道，他们已经学会了他们可以这样做。你只需要继续教导他们，加强诚实对他们的重要性，并保持耐心。总的来说，他们中的大多数人会开始减少撒谎，可能只会在试图保持礼貌的情况下偶尔撒谎
in situations like that. For a very small percentage of children, it may become a problem behavior. And this may be related, it can be a number of reasons. It could be because it's related to some other, problem behaviors, such as children who have conduct disorder or oppositional defined disorder, they are more likely to lie. In fact, this is one of the symptoms of it of these disorders, but very small percentage. And then you're going to see in a constellation of other behaviors, like being aggressive or engaging in sort of more antisocial behavior, being defined of authority,
在这样的情况下。对于极少数儿童来说，这可能会变成一种问题行为。这可能与多种原因有关。可能是因为它与其他问题行为有关，例如患有品行障碍或对立违抗性障碍的儿童，他们更有可能撒谎。事实上，这是这些疾病的症状之一，但比例非常小。然后你会看到一系列其他行为，比如具有攻击性或从事更多反社会行为，违抗权威，
etc. So if you're seeing a range of these behaviors including a line, you may wish to seek help just to find out, you know, if your child. And this should be like over a period of time, it shouldn't be like, you know, just one day or one week, but we're talking about, you know, over a period of time, you're seeing this pattern developing. Then you should seek help. The other time that you should seek help is when you are having trouble coping with your child's behavior. Your child's line behavior, you're having difficult coping with it. And it's at a state where you're, you are not able to deal with it. Then also seek help because whether it's a problematic or it's just a phase they're going through or whatever,
等等。所以如果你看到一系列包括撒谎在内的行为，你可能希望寻求帮助，只是为了找出你的孩子是否……这应该是一个持续一段时间的过程，不应该只是某一天或某一周，我们谈论的是在一段时间内，你看到这种模式正在形成。那么你应该寻求帮助。另一个你应该寻求帮助的时候是当你难以应对孩子的行为时。你孩子的撒谎行为，你难以应对。并且已经到了你无法处理的地步。那么也要寻求帮助，因为无论是问题行为，还是他们正在经历的一个阶段，或者其他什么，
that's a good time to get some help for you to how to deal with it and also help with the child if there is anything else. Because really important as children develop, if you really want to maintain honesty and open, honest communication between you and your child, as they go from preschool through elementary school into high school and up into their adult life, you want to have a relationship with them that is based on open and honest communication. And to do that, it's really important to the bond between you and your child is maintained. And there's this bond of trust that's maintained. And if that bond is being compromised and you're having difficulty coping with it,
那是一个寻求帮助的好时机，让你知道如何处理它，如果还有其他问题，也可以帮助孩子。因为非常重要的是，随着孩子的成长，如果你真的想在孩子从学前班到小学、高中一直到成年生活的过程中，保持你和孩子之间诚实、开放的沟通，你希望与他们建立一种基于开放和诚实沟通的关系。要做到这一点，保持你和孩子之间的纽带非常重要。并且要保持这种信任纽带。如果这种纽带受到损害，而你又难以应对，
it's important to seek help to help you with that because as a parent, you're a really important part of that child's life. You're the first educator of the child. The parent is their very first educator from when they're small and you play a significant role in their life, even in the teenage years when they are engaged with the wider world, you still can play a significant role when you have a strong relationship and bond with that child. So you really, if you're there's anything that's compromising that or you just feel you can't cope, just reach out and ask for some help. In addition to studying lying and honesty, you also research children's online interactions,
寻求帮助来协助你是很重要的，因为作为父母，你是孩子生活中非常重要的一部分。你是孩子的第一任教育者。父母是孩子从小到大的第一任教育者，即使在他们进入青少年时期，与更广阔的世界接触时，你仍然可以在与孩子建立牢固的关系和纽带时发挥重要作用。所以，如果有什么事情损害了这一点，或者你只是觉得无法应对，就去寻求帮助吧。除了研究撒谎和诚实，你还研究儿童的在线互动，
including cyberbullying. Is there a connection between that work and your work on lying and truth-telling? Yeah. So part of the reason, like way back when now, when we were early days, early days of smartphones and everything, somebody asked. me about children, you know, posting, you know, false rumors and lies on the internet about other children, which is part of one way of cyberbullying. There's other ways to do it too. And so that sort of started me on that road. And since then we've sort of continued and looked
包括网络欺凌。这项工作和你关于撒谎和说真话的工作之间有联系吗？是的。所以部分原因，回溯到很久以前，当我们处于智能手机和一切事物的早期阶段时，有人问我关于孩子们在互联网上发布关于其他孩子的虚假谣言和谎言的事情，这是网络欺凌的一种方式。还有其他方式。所以这让我走上了那条路。从那时起，我们继续观察
at wider aspects of children's online engagement in the digital world. But there is sort of a connection here in that, you know, even more so. It was even more so just before the the pandemic. And now it's just, you know, just a just normal everyday part of our lives. The digital world is really part of it. Youth engage constantly with the online world through their smartphones, through the computers, many, many different ways. And it's with them at all times. And there are many positive aspects of that. There are many ways we can harness digital technology to help them with their education to help with mental health, too. We can deliver interventions, telehealth, all sorts of positive ways.
儿童在数字世界中在线参与的更广泛方面。但这之间确实有一种联系，你知道，甚至在疫情之前更是如此。现在，这只是我们日常生活中正常的一部分。数字世界确实是其中的一部分。青少年通过智能手机、电脑，以许多许多不同的方式不断地与在线世界互动。它时刻伴随着他们。这有很多积极的方面。我们可以通过多种方式利用数字技术来帮助他们的教育，也有助于心理健康。我们可以提供干预、远程医疗，各种积极的方式。
But the downside of it is you can have negative interactions online too. And before, if your child was being bullied at school, they could come home, they could shut the door, and they could be safe in the cocoon of your home. But now, with that smartphone, it can follow them right up into their bed. and be with them all night long. You can't escape it. So it is of concern to parents and to children and youth. And that's also something that parents have to engage in.
但它的缺点是你在网上也会有负面互动。以前，如果你的孩子在学校被欺负，他们可以回家，关上门，在家的保护伞下感到安全。但现在，有了那部智能手机，它甚至可以一直跟随他们到床上，整晚陪伴着他们。你无法逃避它。所以这对父母、孩子和青少年来说都是一个担忧。这也是父母必须参与的事情。
This is part of our reality and part of youth's regular life. So talking about what's happening online and having conversations about what to do if they see something inappropriate or if they are the target is important even prior to such events. But when we talk to youth about why they don't tell their parents, if they're being bullied online, a lot of times they say that they conceal that information because they're afraid that parents will take their devices away from them. And often the reason the parent takes a device is not because the parent's trying to punish the child, although it feels like punishment to the child.
这是我们现实的一部分，也是青少年日常生活的一部分。因此，谈论网上发生的事情，并就如果他们看到不适当的内容或成为目标时该怎么做进行对话，即使在这些事件发生之前也是很重要的。但当我们和青少年谈论为什么他们不告诉父母他们是否在网上被欺负时，他们很多时候说他们隐瞒这些信息是因为他们害怕父母会没收他们的设备。而父母没收设备的原因通常不是因为父母试图惩罚孩子，尽管对孩子来说这感觉像是惩罚。
They're just very worried about the child and they're trying to keep the child safe. And they see this device as, you know, okay, I'm going to, you better not have the phone. So we had like a 12-year-old had the phone. The parent had given the phone because the child was going to and from school. And they thought for safety reasons. And then the child was being bullied and the parent took the phone away. But that felt like a punishment to that 12-year-old. And so they felt not only were they bullied, but now they've lost this phone that they're so prized.
他们只是非常担心孩子，试图保护孩子的安全。他们把这个设备看作是，你知道，好吧，你最好不要有手机。所以我们有一个12岁的孩子有手机。父母给了手机，因为孩子要往返学校。他们认为是为了安全起见。然后孩子被欺负了，父母把手机拿走了。但这对那个12岁的孩子来说感觉像是一种惩罚。所以他们觉得不仅被欺负了，现在还失去了他们如此珍视的手机。
Right. So we have to think about how we are communicating about, you know, cyberbullying and online engagement. And also when we discover that children are. doing it, we need to be careful not to sort of punish them inadvertently. Because this is the kind of thing that is that fear of those precautions that we hear from youth, why they often lie or don't tell about what's happening online. So what are you working on now? What are the next big questions you want to answer? So the biggest questions are, you know, we know a lot about how it emerges in line. so we know about preschool children and early elementary,
对。所以我们必须考虑我们如何沟通关于网络欺凌和在线参与的问题。而且当我们发现孩子们在这样做时，我们需要小心，不要无意中惩罚他们。因为这就是我们从青少年那里听到的对这些预防措施的恐惧，为什么他们经常撒谎或不告诉网上发生的事情。那么你现在在做什么？你想回答的下一个大问题是什么？所以最大的问题是，我们对它如何在网上出现了解很多，所以我们了解学龄前儿童和小学早期，
that it really is related to their sort of social cognition, what I was saying before, their understanding of other people's minds, their other thought bubbles, understanding their cognition. But what we are interested in is how it then develops over time. For most people, lying is an infrequent occasional behavior, and a lot of people are honest. But for some children and some adults,
它确实与他们的社会认知有关，就像我之前说的，他们对他人思想的理解，他们的其他思维泡沫，理解他们的认知。但我们感兴趣的是它如何随时间发展。对大多数人来说，撒谎是一种不频繁的偶尔行为，很多人是诚实的。但对于一些孩子和一些成年人来说，
lying does become a problematic behavior. So we're interested in looking at that sort of trajectory over time of what is it that predicts why most people learn not to lie, how that may, you know, materialize into different profiles where you have people who are very honest. You have people who are kind of honest some of the time, but dishonest also some of the time. And then you have some people who are being dishonest. And those may be for different reasons. Some may be doing it because it's social. They want people to think well of them. And so they're pathologically lying to make people think that they're great.
撒谎确实变成了一种问题行为。所以我们有兴趣观察这种随时间变化的轨迹，是什么预测了为什么大多数人学会不撒谎，这如何可能转化为不同的概况，比如有些人非常诚实。有些人有时诚实，但有时也不诚实。然后有些人一直在撒谎。这些原因可能不同。有些人这样做是因为它是社交性的。他们希望人们对他们有好的看法。所以他们病态地撒谎，让人们认为他们很棒。
And so they're often telling lies to make themselves appear better. Or there may be people who are lying for very manipulative reasons. And so looking at how that develops over time and how the social factors lead to different profiles of being honest or dishonest. And then what are the most effective ways to intervene to prevent sort of any mass? maladaptive development in children. Well, Dr. Talwar, this has been really interesting. I know you've given a lot of good information to parents and caregivers out there, so I want to thank you for joining me today.
所以他们经常撒谎让自己看起来更好。或者有些人为了非常操纵性的原因而撒谎。所以观察它是如何随时间发展的，以及社会因素如何导致诚实或不诚实的不同概况。然后什么是干预以防止儿童出现任何大规模适应不良发展的最有效方法。好吧，Talwar博士，这真的很有趣。我知道你为家长和看护人提供了很多好的信息，所以我想感谢你今天加入我。
Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman.
谢谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Winerman 制作。
Our sound editor is Chris Kondyen. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的声音编辑是 Chris Kondyen。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。